si de hecho hemos escuchado ahora muy
interesante que justo a la pregunta de
una periodista al
representante de ucrania en este consejo
de seguridad le ha preguntado al
ministro de exteriores- si realmente él
sabía que este ataque va a tener lugar
esta noche y él ha contestado que sabía
que el ataque iba a tener lugar
alrededor de las 8 perdón que sabía que
iban a tener que este ataque iba a tener
lugar esta noche y que de hecho la
petición para que el consejo de
seguridad se reuniera se había hecho a
las 5 para que tuviese lugar a las 8
dice el consejo de seguridad se ha
reunido tarde y lo único que nos ha
quedado es esperar también hemos
escuchado al secretario general de las
naciones unidas antonio guterres ha
vuelto a dar un mensaje desgarrador dice
que ésta ha sido el momento más triste
desde que ha llegado a ocupar este cargo
en las naciones unidas pide a putin de
nuevo que retire sus tropas y que él no
empiece lo que según él ha dicho podría
ser la peor guerra desde el inicio del
siglo 21 hemos visto también el ministro
de asuntos exteriores ucraniano
ha compartido un mensaje a través de su
cuenta de twitter y ha dicho que el
mundo debe y puede detener a vladimir
putin el momento de actuar es ahora
ciudades ucranianas que son ciudades de
paz están ahora mismo en peligro dice
que ucrania se defenderá y vencerá el
mundo debe parar a putin ha dicho ahora
es el momento de actuar un poco la línea
de lo que hemos escuchado hoy en esas
naciones unidas en la que es
precisamente le desafiaba de alguna
manera no al representante de la
federación rusa de si no ha visto el
vídeo del anuncio de su presidente yo
solo puedo mostrar aquí no un mensaje
con el que terminaba que sin un mensaje
muy duro para cerrar este esta jornada
de hoy decía no hay purgatorio para los
criminales de guerra van directos al
infierno el embajador de rusia por su
parte en todo momento ha defendido esta
decisión ha dicho que es para proteger a
los ciudadanos de bombas y ha cerrado
está
este encuentro desde el día de hoy
precisamente pues esto no dándole paso
al representante de ucrania interesante
también destacar una advertencia que ha
hecho putin el presidente ruso vladimir
putin hace muy pocos minutos dice que
cualquier intento extranjero de
interferir en la acción militar de rusia
llevará a consecuencias que nunca se han
visto a una escalada de las tensiones
que eeuu como ha dicho la embajadora de
este país en las naciones unidas ya
llevaba tiempo anunciando se dice que a
pesar de que rusia se haya reído de sus
previsiones y de sus histéricos anuncios
como les cataloga van desde rusia al
final se ha cumplido lo que ellos
habían anunciado desgraciadamente